supporters of the centre-left political
alliance the Zionist Union are out
campaigning in central Tel Aviv
there is little time left till israel's
elections they don't want to see
benjamin netanyahu get a fourth term in
office okay gilma we're here because we
want a new government nothing works in
this country it's always just about
security and that's not in our control
anyway for us the economy and social
issues are more important to horny they
make their way to the campaign bus
emblazoned on it the faces of the
Alliance Isaac Herzog and Sippie Livni
the leaders want to share the role of
Prime Minister Isaac Herzog seen here on
the campaign trail in a bar in Jerusalem
is the face of change for many the 54
year-old lawyer is doing his best to win
new supporters okay oh yes please TT
story have an historic chance for change
help me convince everyone do you really
want four more years of Netanyahu four
more years of this craziness we will win
these elections
poll suggests her socks Union isn't a
neck-and-neck race with the ruling Likud
Party her top promises to lower living
costs and to restart talks with the
palestinians for some his appeal is that
he's not Benjamin Netanyahu Nevada
chandelle OBP first he's not be beat
secondly he's the only one who can beat
bebe thirdly i like the party platform
and it has the potential to finally
bring something good about you know in
person he seems like a real leader sadly
that doesn't really come across on TV or
on the radio but this here is the real
hats ugh oh yeah L suck [ __ ] I know the
campaign isn't Tel Aviv have reached
their final stop of the day they hope
heard sucks party will win big and we'll
have the chance to form a government
that though would present a new
challenge building a stable coalition